el Kelvin ya está fortificado los
legisladores haciendo Cola y todo listo
aquí para la ceremonia en la que se va a
firmar la anexión de estos cuatro
territorios tomados por Rusia en
ucranias también
el mensaje de Moscú ha sido muy claro a
partir de ahora estas zonas pasan a ser
territorio Ruso y serán defendidas con
todo el armamento que tiene en su poder
ahora mismo la federación rusa también
con armamento nuclear lo ha vuelto a
recordar hoy el portavoz de Vladimir
Dimitri Scott que además ha dicho que se
considerará suelo ruso no solo las zonas
que están ahora mismo en poder del
ejército ruso sino también algunas en
las que todavía está el ejército
ucraniano es el caso de la República
Popular de Indonesia cuyas fronteras de
2014 ha dicho Dimitri pescov deben ser
liberadas por las tro